BL you swallowed a tap Worm by accident
what now maybe you ate infected raw meat
or perhaps you drank contaminated water
well that's less important now they're
in your body how bad it might get
depends on whether it's a lava or an egg
option one Lavi once in your intestine
the lava bites into your intestinal wall
where it could spend the next 25 years
growing up to 8 m long eating what you
eat and laying eggs unless you notice
the exx in the toilet you probably
wouldn't even know you had a parasite
you and your new friend and Yogen will
peacefully coexist now option two egg
the eggs need to Feast on something so
they don't stay in your gut instead they
get into your bloodstream then force
their way into muscles developing into
the lvy except sometimes the eggs get
into your brain where they can cause all
sorts of problems by chewing it up this
makes them a leading cause of epilepsy
worldwide fortunately the treatment for
both options is literally a single pill
taken just once the real cure is better
Sanitation